that right what do you guys think about
you think you're cute got man I ain't
going to lie I heard that talking about
himself looking good I'm like this is
tweaking that this ugly mother who's the
hottest dude to you nobody me but
there's nobody better looking than you
yo don't look good to me are there guys
that are ugly I think all guys are ugly
so you're ugly no no I ain't ugly if you
have a son one day do you think your son
would be handsome if you look like me
I'm the only person I look a you have
brothers you have two brothers is one of
them better looking than the other nah
they both ugly I look like my dad like
say your dad's a goodl looking ass no I
a say goodl looking but like he I
though I think Chris Brown look ugly I
think user look ugly I think Barack
Obama look ugly I think Donald who's
more ugly you answer the question do you
get 100 million by societal standards by
societal standards and you just got to
guess thank you for saying that not can
say the truth they both ugly
as